Okay.
Taly Dunevich, thank you so much
for joining me in 20 Minute Leaders.
Thank you for having me.
So so fun to have you.
You know, just before we started the call,
I discovered that you were
a world champion and bronze medalist
in wind surfing.
That's true.
It was when I was very very young.
I'm not actually practicing
that anymore, but yeah.
And you were the Israeli national champion
for quite some time as well.
Yes. Yes.
Unbelievable.
So, first of all, let's start with that.
Tell me, what is it like being
a national champion of a sport?
And actually Israel,
with the beach and the waves,
I mean, there's a lot of people surf.
So, it's not just like a random sport
that you picked up.
It's pretty popular.
And then what is it like going
to the world championship
and actually getting a medal?
That's an amazing feeling to get a medal
and to compete against world champions.
It was a great experience
as I was a girl back then.
I was in high school and then the army.
This is the times
when I was actually doing that
and just being among the team
the Israeli team,
which was I was the only woman.
Still the only women in everything
I'm currently doing
in many areas in my life.
But back then I was the only woman
in the Israeli game.
And when we went to competitions
around the world,
I was kind of sleeping
with guys in the room.
They were taking showers.
They didn't even notice
I was actually a woman.
They kind of missed that.
So, I was really part of,
it was very unique time.
And I actually think
it really helps me today
because today I always find myself also
the only woman in the room
in most business environments,
I mean, IT kind of.
So, I feel very comfortable
because I grew up this way.
So, I'm already very very comfortable
being with a room or an ocean or a sea
or monitor improvements. So, it was fine.
Unbelievable. So, yeah.
So, you're not just an executive
in a tech company,
but you're actually an executive
in a deep technology tech company.
Ayehu Software and technologies.
I mean, it's leveraging
artificial intelligence
and machine learning to do some
really fantastic things.
And being an executive there
and vice president
of Strategic Partnerships and Alliances.
I mean, you're talking about
really understanding the technology,
but also understanding the other people
and the other in other companies.
And I guess in a similar industry,
which still today is still unfortunately
dominated by male counterparts, right?
Yeah.
And is that changing?
Or is that the norm?
What do you see
happening now in this domain?
I see a change. I see more women.
Not enough in leadership positions.
I see the more kind of coming of
as developers and program managers.
You see more and more of them.
Yeah.
And I'm inviting more women
and girls and join.
Of course.
By the way, Taly, I have to tell you
because I got so excited today.
This is not relevant to our conversation.
But I discovered
coconut water in the US today.
I never had it in my life in Israel.
And I'm obsessed with it.
So, these interviews,
I'm only drinking coconut water.
It's really really good coconut water.
It has actually a lot of electrolytes
and everything that you need
for your bodies, your workout
and everything.
It's really, really good.
When I went to Burning Man,
this is the one thing I really packed.
My entire RV was full with coconut water
because I was told that
this is a good thing to have in Burning Man
when you kind of you're not
really taking care of your nutrition.
Wonderful. Wonderful.
Okay. So, right before we started,
you're an expert on building
alliances and relationships.
And what I mentioned was that
I like talking about the things
that the guest or the leader
is passionate about.
And you immediately said,
I'm not passionate about alliances.
I'm passionate about people.
Tell me what that means to you.
So, alliance is just a piece of paper
where you write who is doing what, right?
So, I'm not passionate
about papers and words too much.
I'm more passionate about,
I'm very privileged to be doing
day in and day out what I love doing.
And I meet people.
And I meet people from different cultures
and different backgrounds.
I worked a lot with India, which is huge.
And I just love it.
And people in Europe and Nordics
and Israel and North America.
So, I work with all cultures.
I just love the platform,
or the agenda is a business agenda.
But just meeting people.
Meeting and understanding
where they come from.
What drives them.
What beliefs they come from.
This is what I'm really,
I'm very very fascinated about
human beings in general.
So, my work allows me to explore more
my area of passion, which is people.
And through that,
when you're really interested,
when you're really curious in people
in where they're looking for
and what they wanna get.
I think it's a great way
to really accomplish
what you're also want to do for business.
Like to get the results,
to get the bottom line,
to get revenues,
because you can really build,
I really care.
I really, very fast, I built
relationship trust with people
because I really care and I really love,
I love them.
I don't know,
there is no other ways to say that.
It may sound corny,
but I really love people.
It's incredible and actually right.
As we're having this discussion,
we're talking about
an internship program for the fund
that we're both involved with, J-Ventures.
And going through the details
and seeing how passionate you are
in helping the future generation
and how they are going to be
integrated within
and learn from the fund
and the things that we're doing.
I think that speaks exactly
to what you're describing here.
And I wanna take you back a few years.
Talk to me a little bit about
how you form these relationships
in the business setting.
So, these are not just friends.
They're business friends that you're
forming alliances and relationships.
My imagination and tell me if I'm wrong,
is that, two years ago or three years ago,
you wanna form a business relationship.
You hop on a plane, you go over there,
you visit the offices,
you go out to dinner,
you go out to a Broadway show,
and you talk
and you slowly build that trust.
Is that fairly accurate?
I never took anyone to a Broadway show,
I have to say.
But that's the whole point.
That's why you do it.
No. You don't have,
I know that, it's difficult to say.
It tells people
you will dine and wine you
and all these stuff.
I do that to some extent, but not really.
It's really like, even through Zoom.
You don't need to take them
to fancy places or anything.
Just really speaking to people
and understanding where they come from.
Finding the common ground.
You always have something in common
with another person.
Right.
Really fast. If you're curious enough,
go find what it is
and you can build from there.
And then you have the initial connection.
And once you have that,
you'll learn more about each other.
And we're all just humans.
Even if we come
from different backgrounds.
There is so much in common.
There is more in common
than not in common.
And just you take down to barriers
and then you can, when you have trust
and you have connection,
you can build everything with it.
Anything with it.
So, just human connection.
I don't know.
No, no.
I mean, it sounds great.
But now, I wanna take us to 2020.
Yeah.
The great 2020,
that everybody likes to say.
Yeah.
And we're in the middle of the year now.
We're a little bit more than the middle.
And how do you build relationships?
I joined a company,
a wonderful wonderful company,
Hippo Insurance.
I did my entire on-boarding remotely.
I didn't meet, I met one person
from my team in person.
The rest are only through video.
How can I, or how should I build
a meaningful relationship
with my colleagues over remote?
Is it different?
Is it easier or harder?
So, this is not the only
form of communication.
Yes. So, we use a lot of Zoom
and you go onto video calls.
I think it's a great medium
to connect deeply with people.
But we see it like we really look
at each other when the camera is on
and not off.
And people really look at each other
in the eyes.
I think it's very very close.
I don't see a lot of difference.
Sometimes it's even an advantage.
When in a room of people,
sometimes, some people
are not really related to the call
or to the meeting and,
I see disadvantage
and advantages to this medium.
I don't find it harder
to do business over Zoom
than I've done meeting face to face.
And is that also true
for meeting new people
or forming new relationships?
Yes.
Because I understand the transition from
existing relationships, continuing them.
But is that the same case also
for finding new partners
and getting to that same level
of intimacy?
Because you're missing
a lot of your senses, right?
You're missing smell, touch.
You're basically only going base to sound.
I think it's a good thing
to miss the smell part.
Well, I would assume that when you go
and build a business relationship,
then you make an effort to smell.
No. So, it's interesting
because this is really counter-intuitive
to everything that I thought of
what's happening today.
First of all,
I have a lot of new relationships
that I'm forming in the past four months
when I'm working from home now
and I'm not traveling anywhere.
So, I've been I've been forming.
And in the process
of forming new relationship
with new companies,
with new minute service providers,
its largest size.
And it's going really well.
I'm actually more efficient
because I'm sitting here all day
meeting after meeting.
I can do more in the same amount of time.
I don't need to travel around anywhere.
And I can be very very focused
on what I'm doing.
And I have all my things here
and my notes.
Like I'm very very organized.
And I'm way more efficient.
So, I'm doing so much more activities
per day because I'm not traveling
and I don't have even
the office distractions.
And I don't need to be nice
to anyone around me
and have coffee with them during the day.
I can just really focus on work
which I love doing.
And I can do more.
And I can have one on ones.
And when I started relationship
with somebody,
I'm also connecting with them
via WhatsApp.
And starting other forms.
And then we're imagining the time,
the day that we will actually be able to,
or I'm going to have dinner
with them or something.
So, hopefully that will come soon.
I think it's fascinating how it impacts
so many different facets of our work.
And I definitely see the upside
and the downside of having this new norm.
Tell me a little bit about
what does it mean alliance building
in terms of corporate?
So, you're part of a big organization
that has IT services.
Why are alliances important
and what are alliance is actually
in the tech world?
So, it's really important.
Specifically in my company,
the alliance as far represent
over 60% of our revenues.
So, I'm responsible in my own company
for over 60%.
And this is why it's so important,
it really drives a lot of business
and it's way more efficient.
So, in our company,
we have direct team
that is selling directly to the enterprise
and we have the partners team,
which is my team,
and we're selling through partners.
So, and this part with less people,
we sell much more.
So, it's more efficient.
It's like opening the doors to
a more strategic long term relationship
versus just selling to one enterprise,
then to another enterprise.
When I form relationship
with our partners,
for example, the global GSIs of the world
like Accenture, Deloitte,
Cognizant, Capgemini,
just to name a few of the partners
that I'm working with.
So, when I formed this
trusted relationship
and we build the right
go to market plan together,
that opens the door
for my company to get to
40 of their accounts.
So, in forming one large alliances,
we can actually sell 40 licenses
versus one by one.
So, this is the opportunity.
And this is why it's very important.
And I really believe that today
in SAS companies, any company
that is selling software today,
partnership I think it's already
as it should be.
It will be a more integral
and big part of their business,
because today it's all about
the ecosystem.
The ecosystem you build around you.
It's like the ISPs, the GSIs,
all the different partners
that you're strategically engaging with.
And it's a win-win.
It helps them, helps us.
It's all about working together
and having synergetic type of results
out of that for both sides.
It has to work for everyone.
And that makes a lot of sense.
And then do the relationships
usually occur between key people
in both organizations?
Or is it organization to organization?
In other words,
you're building a relationship now
with another organization,
let's say Deloitte,
and then you're building it with
key people there
that are agreeing to this.
Let's say tomorrow they're advancing
to their next adventure,
how difficult is it to make
that transition of alliance
to another person?
Because you have to, all of a sudden
build trust and relationship
with another person who has to decide
whether to renew this relationship,
to renew this partnership, right?
So, when I'm building the relationship,
so first, yes, we're building it
with key people.
Key people and key people.
So, this is top down relationship.
But I'm also, even during the sale cycle,
I'm taking care of the bottom up as well.
So, making sure that their people
are getting certified and trained.
Right. Okay.
Making sure I create demands
on the different pockets
on the business level.
But kind of one layer,
two layers below that are actually
taking care of their account.
So, making sure they understand the value
and what it brings to their clients.
Making sure that they really are building
the incentives for them to work with us.
So, when you build it
with the top key people
and with the business level,
which is the medium unit director level,
that really manage accounts.
And you build it also
with the developers and operators,
and delivery people and service people.
On more the technical level
enablement type of thing.
So, you build anything,
all the levels in the right way
with a very defined
go to market plan and KPIs.
Everybody are aligned around KPI.
And you just manage this entire process.
Then it's really,
you're getting very very sticky.
It's really hard to leave you.
It's actually no reason to leave you.
You also have their personal relationship.
They will not just ditch you
for some reason.
You can identify if you have an issue
with anything.
And if there is any competition
that is threatening you
and addressed it before.
Of course. And when I want to,
when I have an ambition
to be a software engineer at a company,
I go and I study computer science.
I go online and I teach myself
how to code in Python or Java
or JavaScript.
When you want to be
in alliances and partnerships,
I don't believe there's a major for that.
I don't believe there is
an online text book.
Maybe there are some
self-help books on Amazon.
But it sounds like it's a lot of practice
on the job and on the field.
How do you prepare
for a position like that?
How do even set yourself up
to go and become a VP of that
at a company?
That's an awesome question.
I think the greatest university
for the work that I do called "life",
so,  if you're really,
and for me specifically,
this is really an area that I love.
I study like for my own fun
on the side.
I study brain science
and consciousness and spirituality.
And I have so much interest in human beings
and how we use this box here
in the top of our body called "brain".
And how we can really maximize it
and understand our beliefs
and how it drives us.
So, specifically for me,
I'm so interested in this area,
called "people",
and how everything works
in the universe altogether.
That, this is I think, for me
is  the best school.
Because everything,
all the books that I'm reading,
the podcast that I'm listening to,
or around those areas and I'm just,
Of course.
That really helps me in work,
I have to say.
But Taly, you're already a vice president
at a huge company.
How do you get to be a vice president
of partnerships and alliances
at a huge company?
Because you need that break
to be able to go and learn through life.
Is it easy to get this break?
Do you join, like where do you start
in order to get to that level?
It's the opposite of taking break of life
to learn something.
It's the opposite.
It's the more you're engaging in life
and the more you're busy.
So, I'm involve in many many things.
I'm involve in J-Ventures, right?
And now I'm helping putting together
the internship programs.
And through everything I do,
And I'm involved in high powered women.
And I'm involved in so many organizations.
The more I involve,
the more I have connections,
I have an amazing rolodex.
I know a lot of people.
I have a great network.
So, that's access
to just about everything.
So, anywhere I want to get to,
to get to know this person,
I can always get connected by somebody.
People will always help me.
My door is always open to helping others.
And I'm always,
my mission in life
is to really help others
grow in whatever they do.
So, I think the more you are,
you don't need to take a break
to learn that.
Actually the other way around.
Be engaged.
Stick with people, network.
Be fully in, in the game of life,
and that really helps
those type of positions
like business development and alliances.
And then, how knowledgeable
do you have to be on the tech side
of things to really understand?
Because at the end,
you're selling a product.
You're not actually selling.
You're finding ways to collaborate.
But at the end you have to understand,
That's okay. I'm selling.
I'm not hiding from it.
No, no. Do you consider it selling?
I am.
Because when I think of alliances
or partnerships, I think of
a win-win situation for both parties.
Well, it's true.
But I've been compensated for bottom lines
for revenues that I actually bring
to the companies.
So, it's very very measurable.
What I'm bringing  it's on my paycheck.
I can actually see how it's going.
I'm measured.
So, that's very much sells.
That's very much in line.
So, how do you have people get to that,
the tech side?
So, I'm not a techie.
I'm not an engineer.
I'm just learning everything I feel
when I have a gap
by just asking or learning
or going on YouTube
and reading and understanding.
And I always have like, not always,
but when at some point in the processes,
I am bringing more an engineer
to actually join me
through those calls and insert
a deep technical questions.
But on the high level,
I'm good enough to convey the benefits
the business outcomes.
And to even run through a demo
and be a bit technical to a degree,
not all the way.
So, it sounds like what you're saying
is that your strengths
or your're ability to really,
to look at others, understand their needs.
Understand both technology
but also business see, what does
Ayehu software technologies provide
and then finding that
sweet spot of collaboration
where you can you can provide
the services to them.
And then along the process later on,
you can provide that engineering input,
which can do a much deeper dive.
Which is not necessary
when you're at first in the high level
of what is this partnership
that we're gonna do.
Perfect. You answered it.
Okay. Wonderful.
Taly, what should I take away from this
as a young entrepreneur
as I go on my next venture,
what do I need to know in terms of
partnerships, alliances, maybe even
just selling products to others?
I was in general, I always like,
my first rule, even for myself,
is follow your heart.
So, follow your heart.
I'm trying to follow mine
and trying to understand what it tells me.
At times when it's not very clear,
this is the first life advice.
I think you'll be a great candidate
for any business development position
because you're such a people person.
Thank you.
Already.
And you have no problem
in just interacting with just about
anybody in any level at any.
So, you have everything you need.
You just need the content
to discuss about.
Which is like for me,
it's Ayehu today.
Tomorrow, I don't know.
Or yesterday it was something else.
But it's the same thing.
So, you already
have everything you need
You're perfect.
If you're looking for something,
let me know.
Wonderful. Thank you.
Thank you very much, Taly.
Before we leave,
I have to ask you
the most important question.
My favorite question.
Three words that you would use
to describe yourself
or that any of your clients
would use to describe Taly.
So, I think the first thing
that comes to mind is what I said
throughout the session.
I'm a people person,
so, really loving people.
And just I'm really grateful
to be able to do that everyday,
for many hours every day.
A second thing.
What can it be?
Oh, so, I am a constant learner.
I always learn new things
and growth and learning.
I study quantum physics,
and consciousness and brain science.
And I just love learning new things
not even related to my work.
Everything becomes related at the end,
by the way.
Everything is getting connected.
But you just, I always,
like I run every day.
I always listen to audiobooks
or podcast or something.
Even when I take a shower,
I'm just having something.
So, I always learn something.
What's your favorite audiobook
that you read recently?
Hit Refresh by Satya Nadella,
which is kind of a biography
which was really good.
And he was referencing to growth mindset,
by the way, speaking about growth.
He was referencing some Stanford
professor who wrote the book "Mindset".
And he really changed the entire culture
in Microsoft around this approach.
I don't know if you agree with that.
So, this were two great books
that I've read recently.
[--] power of now,
lead your life to spirituality.
Definitely.
And I need the third word.
So, I have people person.
I have constant learner.
Third, I would say I'm driven.
So, I'm involved in so many things.
I just drive things.
And my husband calls me "my engine".
I'm his engine.
I just let everything that I love,
if it's work,
driving business, driving sales,
helping Jay Ventures in the fund
or anything else I'm involve.
Just driving things forward.
I'm very task oriented to the degree
that I'm not trying to relax a little bit.
So, yeah.
So, I would say
those are the main three things.
Tally, toda raba.
Thank you very very much.
And stay safe and stay healthy.
Thank you. Bye bye.